la 5e conférence mondiale sur le sida
s'est ouverte aujourd'hui à montréal au
canada avec cette déclaration terrible
d'un représentant africain d'où la
maladie est originaire je le cite en
afrique centrale
la propagation du sida est comparable à
la vitesse d'un feu de forêt sur les
cent mille décès dus au sida dans le
monde près de 25000 concerne d afrique
si rien ne vient endiguer cette maladie
ce sont des pays entiers d'afrique de ce
continent dont qui risque de disparaître
l'exemple eh bien nous sommes allés le
chercher dans l'une de ces nations
menacé au coeur du mal dans un village
de tanzanie enquête dan guez burget et
philippe manteau asie cet enfant va
mourir son père a dû le porter ainsi
pendant trois heures car on vient de
loin et afia qui garent hama le seul
dispensaire de la région aucun médecin
juste trois infirmiers à peine quelques
aspirine
dérisoire face à un petit garçon atteint
du sida déjà inconscient pourtant il a
fallu la présence de la caméra et notre
insistance pour que cet enfant ne soit
pas renvoyé chez lui
l'infirmière avait diagnostiqué une
indigestion
le lendemain jason ne s'est pas réveillé
il avait 12 ans un drame ordinaire dans
cette région du nord de la tanzanie
ici où le lac victoria s'étend vers
l'ouganda c'est tout un peuple qui c'est
un cachet nier village frontière le sida
il fait des ravages
un mort tous les dix jours la maladie a
déjà emporté une centaine d'adultes sur
les mille habitants que comptait le
village orphelins les enfants se
regroupent entre frères et soeurs entre
voisins des enfants parfois veiller
parent grand-parent les gars rester
seuls avec leur mort partout les tombes
s'aligne derrière la maison
cette vieille femme s'occupe seule de
ses 16 petits enfants comme les quatre
fils sont morts et après leurs femmes
tous le sida en fait une catastrophe
quand je serais morte qui veillera sur
les enfants
le sida frappe toute la population
hommes et femmes en âge d'activité
sexuelle contamination d'autant plus
facile que la polygamie est très
répandue dans cette famille il y a plus
d'homme
ce bébé élevé par sa grand-mère
orphelins aussi deux maisons plus loin à
bella 20 ans déjà évident sur sa peau
les traces du sida je vivais dans un
autre village avec mon mari
il y a deux mois en est tombé malade
alors on est retourné chacun dans notre
famille ici je suis mieux c'est ma grand
mère qui s'occupe de moi à bella était
sans doute séropositif depuis longtemps
tout comme ce bébé
il a deux ans et demi ses parents sont
morts il ya deux ans du sida au village
ils sont aujourd'hui 270 orphelins
livrés à eux mêmes comment vont-ils
grandir alors qu'il faut d'abord
simplement apprendre à survivre survivre
en travaillant les plus grands vont aux
champs on cultive pommes de terre manioc
et banane les plus jeunes ont encore
parfois la chance d'aller à l'école
70 écoliers pour un seul mètre ce qui
manque est essentielle les cahiers et
des bancs pour tout le monde
le chef du village alerté les autorités
sur le problème du sida et des orphelins
sans résultat nous sommes actuellement
aidé par l'église pour informer les gens
on leur dit d'arrêter les échanges de
partenaires on prône la fidélité dans le
mariage
un homme doit avoir une seule femme nous
avons vraiment besoin d' aide pour tous
ces orphelins qui n'ont plus rien de
l'aide n'est pas n'importe laquelle car
au mois de janvier l'unique épicerie de
cash aigner a reçu un stock de
préservatifs expédier des états unis
préservatif que le pasteur et le chef du
village ont aussitôt confisquer les
distribuer serait offense et coutumes et
religions entêtement rigueur morale
inadaptée à une telle urgence en outre
le premier hôpital de la région est à 60
kilomètres de là il faut sept heures de
très mauvaises routes pour y arriver
doolaeghe et seulement cinq médecins
pour 220 lits mais on veut donner
l'exemple
le test de dépistage du sida et
systématique avant chaque transfusion
les chiffres terrifiants un patient sur
deux sirops positif il faut maintenant
éviter que d'autres enfants comme celui
ci soit accidentellement contaminés par
injection pour lui sa mère c'est qu'il
est trop tard
absolument pas
claire médicaments donc les gens sont de
toute façon condamnée à courte et un
bien parce que mon âme at il est
considéré comme un moyen de prévention
dollars le gouvernement est il emploie
des le canapé ce qu'on appelle économe
l'avait pas tarbaise il envoie isla au
gouvernement mais moi je travaille dans
un hôpital et l'église comme ça nous
n'en avons encore un long placement et
des neiges de se protéger
nous encourageons plutôt les chants jeux
de cordes les changements de
comportement cet homme à 34 ans atteint
du sida
il est venu pour qu'on l'aide à mourir
symbole en tanzanie un peu plus
disparaît dans cette vallée du rift qui
fut il ya trois millions d'années le
berceau de l'humanité